a friend who was like
he didn't know anything about joycon
drift
and they were like yeah i don't know how
it was joycon drift you don't know
anything about joycon i obviously don't
play my uh
enough it's when the d-pad just does so
unfortunately there's a massive lawsuit
going on i don't know if it's been
resolved with nintendo and a bunch it's
a class action um essentially the
controllers after like a random period
of time they just start drifting the
joy-con like the the joysticks
right it's not just the joy-cons either
the pro controllers do the same thing
yeah and it's been a massive problem and
people have to buy so many joy-cons and
true contents aren't cheap they're like
60 bucks yeah 60-70 bucks ridiculous and
um yeah and they just they drift and i
had a friend who's playing it
and bless them they're not really a
gamer and they were like yeah so when
i'm playing it sometimes i just go to
the side why is that i'm like first time
yes so nintendo made a shitty product
that doesn't [ __ ] work so you have to
deal with it buy a new one if you don't
like it spend more money yeah nintendo
says they'll fix it as well then they
have like warranty
i think the last thing that something
like that happened to me was uh the
infamous xbox red rings of death oh yeah
bro that was such a debacle
what a [ __ ] clown fiesta
do you have to send your xbox away to
microsoft no no so like i i did this
like [ __ ] gorilla tactic that i found
on the internet of like now now that i
know what i'm doing i was just basically
overheating the xbox so what you do is
you [ __ ] wrap a towel around it and
then no i'm i'm actually serious
you wrap a towel around it and then you
turn on the xbox and leave it for like a
few hours so you're just basically over
here
yeah you're overheating and cooking your
[ __ ] cpu or something you think
there's like a 4chan
for some inexplicable reason it worked
and i have no idea why wait wait so do
you want to explain what the red ring of
death is for people who don't know
um so back when xbox released their xbox
360. they rushed it out and it was
poorly manufactured yeah had many
problems yeah so if you bought one of
the first consoles first generation
consoles that were released um you
basically had a time limit right it was
basically like a year or two and every
xbox had this where you play and then
one day for one reason that nobody could
tell it just wouldn't work right and so
you would get the three rings right so
when the xbox turned when the xbox turns
on right you would um you'd see like a
green ring around the power button yeah
yeah yeah and basically there were it
was split into four segments and
uh the red rings of death meant three
segments were read which was mean
something was wrong with the startup
right and
nobody like we called it the red rings
of death because everyone had this issue
i know and it never got resolved and how
you would resolve it is to basically
send it back to the manufacturer it cost
microsoft billions yes because of all
this [ __ ] because it happens so often
right and my friend i had two friends
about it so we had a group of four of us
who all played xbox yeah and i never got
it thank god i would have actually cried
because what my friend had to go through
sounded like my worst nightmare is a 16
year old me yeah he he got the red ring
of death and he had to send it back and
then they sent back a box that an xbox
that was refurbished it was someone
else's and it didn't work yeah what so
and again like this so they're just
recycling xboxes apparently they had
they were doing stuff like this like it
was pretty widespread so you sent it and
they called them up again this is like
over months like this took i think it
took like half a year to get it fixed
overall he had sent about like three
times before they finally fixed it and
then and then it broke six months later
and he just gave up he was like i'm not
doing it again yeah i'm not sending it
out
i mean this is that that literally like
scared me to death i was like the
thought of my xbox dying i was like this
is my only this is my lifeline like if
this goes what am i gonna do i don't
know what i'm gonna do if i can't play
halo reach i'm gonna lose it
it's gonna be everyone's problem